It is often useful to look at specific problem domains,
both to see how we can apply current theories of chronological reasoning to them
and also to see how we can use those problem domains to build new theories of
chronological reasoning. So let us turn now to the domain of design. In design,
there is a new movement that is sometimes called biologically inspired design,
or biomimicry. This movement is pulled by the need for
environmental sustainability and is pushed by the desire for creativity and
innovation and design. On the top left here is a picture of
the Shinkansen 500 train in Japan. This is a bullet train. It's called a bullet
train because of the shape of its nose. This particular shape is inspired by
the shape of the beak of the Kingfisher. The story goes something like this.
Japanese railway engineers were interested in building faster trains.
However, they had a problem, these trains had to go through tunnels. And
as they went through tunnels, they created shock waves, which created a lot of
noise, bothering the neighbors. The shock wave was created because outside
the tunnel and inside the tunnel were two different mediums. By serendipity,
the railway engineers looked at how the Kingfisher goes from the medium of
air into a medium of water, dips its beak and catches its prey.
The shape of its nose allows us to create a smaller shock wave.
We use the same principle to create the design of the nose of the bullet train.
Shinkansen 500 travels faster than previous trains and
also makes less noise than previous trains, mostly because of the nose shape.
Another example often cited in biomimicry is the example of a Mercedes Benz box
car, designed by inspiration to the Boxfish. Notice as biological
inspired design entails analogical reasoning. There's a target problem.
There's a source case. There is cross-domain analogical transfer.